je n'ai pas eu de belles mais au fond de
moi je suis sur moi que j'ai du talent
se complaît bleus ya trente ans que je
porte et mes chansons onirique et moi
pour le cacher
je fais du porte à porte pour subsister
avec n'importe quoi je n'ai connu que
un succès facile
[Musique]
et
seul
les mineurs le cacher
vous apportez les petits meubles et des
bas
pas moyen de la photographie
bras de cela
au soleil
[Musique]
pour attendre ma vie
leur désabusé des débutants friande con
devrait car les soirs
miller
ce tout paris
bon
lancé par terre
entrée sur la scène sous les ovations et
les projecteurs j'ai tout essayé
pourtant pour sortir une
j'ai chanté l'amour effet du comique et
la fantaisie
si tout a raté pour moi je suis dans
l'ombre
ce n'est pas ma faute mais celle du
public qui n'a rien
andry en hommage à ray accordé ma chance
on aurait eu si peu de moi et beaucoup
d'argent
peut-être en plus
peu trop qu'on avance
mais un jour viendra je leur montrerai
j'ai du talent
[Musique]